do have the story pulled up from the GMG
Union this is the I believe it's the
Gizmodo Media Group this is big news
check it out and the onion Union our
statement on Geo media's plan to
implement AI content just days after
laying off Newsroom members ladies and
gentlemen I'm not a big fan of Jezebel
Jalopnik Kotaku Deadspin Etc Gizmodo but
uh I stand with them on this now
personally I think it's fantastic if
these people ultimately lose their jobs
because I am a
remorseless and ruthless in the the
left-wing lies perpetrated by these
individuals are horrifying the reality
is a i Jezebel is 50 million times worse
than some random feminist complaining on
the internet they write
on June 29th geomedia inform editorial
staff that will begin a modest test of
AI content on its websites the AV club
Deadspin Gizmodo Jalopnik Jezebel Kotaku
quartz the root and the takeout
as the unionized editorial staffers of
geomedia organized The Writers Guild of
America East we are appalled by this
news the hard work of journalists cannot
be replaced by unreliable AI programs
notorious for creating falsehoods and
plagiarizing the work of real writers
oh no journalists uh don't do anything
dude they've literally found a perfect
replicas that's right yeah and for lower
cost our newsrooms have spent decades
building trust with audiences sure
introducing computer-generated garbage
undermines our ability to do our jobs
erodes trust in us as journalists
damages Our Brands and threatens our
jobs okay they're firing you though they
don't care about your jobs they don't
care about you now here's what I gotta
say man that's a tough one to read these
people have no trust they don't they
these these org these these news
websites have been sold and over end
because nobody reads them they they
produce an article to get viral clicks
someone will read it and then leave and
not come back they have no core base
that's why they're struggling and
failing Tim cast for instance is doing
better than ever because we actually
have an audience and we care about our
audience we built up trust with our
Audience by trying to be trustworthy
they don't
but I gotta say it
if these websites Implement AI it will
be worse than you could imagine because
the AI will be unchecked and it will be
just pulling a bunch of random garbage
on the internet compiling it to a
paragraph that's not real yeah and
people will believe it and where it gets
worse it's not about one website doing
it it's the fact that all of these
websites the AI they get will be reading
the AI articles they write Gizmodo will
AI generate an article that Jezebel's AI
will read it will then compile that AI
article into a new article which Gizmodo
will then read and then make an article
which Jezebel will read you get my point
if the AI models are only learning from
other AI news websites the end result is
going to be a whole bunch of fake news
worse than you've ever seen now I can
also say this there is a positive
possibility
if they do this they are essentially
destroying themselves these people are
getting fired they're losing their jobs
it's the end of these organizations and
the AI garbage content will only work
for a couple years at best so maybe we
say if they want to set a fire that
destroys them why should we intervene my
view is that fire will spread everywhere
on the internet and eventually you'll
see some conservative be like here's an
article from conservative news dot you
know news or whatever that says Donald
Trump does backflip and the source is
you know conservative trends.com whose
source is Fox News and fox saw it on
Gizmodo and Gizmodo wrote the whole
thing up fake from an AI
it will be too confusing if we allow
this to happen my fear it's gonna happen
anyway
so at the very least I can express I
oppose it
but I think it's coming anyway I'd like
to have some of these reporters
journalists whatever you want to call
them on the show these people that are
being fired it's as you were talking Tim
I've started to think of Jesus talking
about bring me your huddled masses
you're tired you're poor however you
said it but bring them bring them
they're they're allowed I think you're
talking about the Statue of Liberty
didn't Jesus say like bring me the weak
among you the the sick the poor is that
your Liberty okay yeah I'm not a
Christian but what didn't Jesus also
acknowledge like he cared for the poor
and loved the poor so I'm talking about
man so these people are they're they're
about to be cast aside into the dregs of
society they're being fired from it
already in my opinion crappy Institution
I think it's now it's time to to accept
like to be there for them you want to
hire them tell their stories no I want
to have them on and and hear them
complain about what happened to them
I'll hire them
absolutely oh boy yeah uh it's the it's
called the Goku method well the thing is
I won't uh uh see listen you gotta
understand it's a very important live
lesson when Vegeta tried to destroy the
Earth okay and was fighting with Kakarot
Goku and the the Z team converted Vegeta
into one of their allies and now he's
actually one of the most popular
characters Abraham Lincoln that's how
you gotta do so we gotta hire them and
turn them into good good guys do you
think there's anyone behind the scenes
at these places who have become
disillusioned and actually would like to
work here I'm willing to think there's a
possibility that at least there's got to
be at least one person at one of these
places I I am half kidding but I am
willing to bet a good portion of people
who work there are only saying what they
think they have to say to get by in a
city yeah and if someone came along and
said how would you like to own your own
house have an acre of land to yourself
and not have to worry about this anymore
I'm willing to buy a bunch of them say
sure oh yeah okay you can move out to
Western Maryland and West Virginia where
you can buy a house for substantially
cheaper than a condo in New York City
you'll have land you'll have a car
you'll have clean fresh air and no one
will will come down on you for saying
that that's the real Revolution is the
people that are waking up realizing that
careers and livelihoods will be stripped
by artificial intelligence and a
technocracy going to take their power
back like creating their own jobs in
their own communities
that's how it's going to work yeah I
mean look I'm hap look and I said this
before
um when we were talking about another
media Outlet we won't name going under
and I understand this no one here has
technically gone under but there's a
potential for it I hope that these
people find more productive work than
writing lies for a living
well at least hope they have a Great
Awakening I mean I'm sure a lot of these
news networks they celebrate if a coal
mine shuts down or a factory gets moved
overseas to to China or to Mexico or
wherever it may be uh and you know I'm
not excited about the the with AI Rising
I don't I personally don't want AI to
replace truck drivers because driving
truck is a top profession for men who
don't graduate high school or just have
a GED
um you know and so like I don't
necessarily want journalists to lose
their jobs but a lot of these
journalists have cheered on have cheered
other Industries like coal miners
because of the you know
environmentalists uh in the in the in
the journalist newsrooms they hate coal
they hate oil and so they cheer every
time like a pipeline gets shut down or
something like that and tens of
thousands of people are put out of work
but uh hopefully they use this as an
opportunity to be like you know what
maybe I'll stop writing uh cheerful
articles about the these rural working
class Americans losing their jobs I
don't think they will ever stop hating
Real working-class Americans to be
honest but here yeah I wish it happened
but it doesn't matter let me tell you a
story right it was uh Brian krasnstein
recently put out a tweet about Libs of
tick tock and a feud ensued and uh he
shouted us out saying he wrote Tim Poole
wrote the most Fair uh and correct
assessment of what happened with the
story it was actually Chris Bertman a
writer who wrote the story up and Our
intention with timcast news is literally
just to tell you what happened I don't
care if you agree or disagree with Brian
krasenstein we've had him on the show
disagree with him on a lot of things
agree with him on some things I think we
had a good conversation you know he's a
liberal guy Chris burtman wrote the
story as it was
krasenstein tweets he's like I can't
believe it he's like it's it's Tim Poole
who's writing the honest listen
maybe that will you know a little light
bulb on for the krasensteins if you are
reading Tim cast news you are getting
our best attempt at just telling you
what's happening we are not trying to
trick you or manipulate you or help
anybody win an election
that's how you get it done
the problem is these people at these
companies like Gizmodo Jezebel whatever
they're they're lying for clicks why
well their bosses tell them to not so
much overtly they say hey you're not
pulling your weight your articles aren't
doing very well so what does the writer
do chases the algorithm to try and
figure out what gets the most clicks
timcast news does not exist to generate
Revenue it exists because we want there
to be some good uh effective journalism
out there be it illad aliyahu on the
ground in New York capturing that viral
video that took over the internet for
the past week though we're coming for
your children thing or an article by
Chris Bertman explaining
just what the feud was to the point
where Ryan Cranston is like wow thank
you for being honest about what happened
it's not like it's a positive story
about him it's just we're not lying
about him yeah we're not going to make
money off that and we don't need to we
just want there to be a source for news
that does does a good job
news I don't think can be a big money
maker I think it's Gotta like so that's
that's basically what we do I'll stress
this when you become a member at
timcast.com understand that your
membership helps support the news the
writing that we do at timcast.com the
news reports we do and journalists like
a lot on the ground at these at these
marches just filming what they're saying
ilad didn't put out a video and say I
can't believe they would say this these
people are discussing he literally just
tweeted Marchers say x fact statement
and then everybody was shocked by it it
created this big hub-up that's the point
of doing good news of doing not good
news but doing journalism right
these people are just they're in it for
the clicks and the revenue you can't run
a business that way yeah I'm also you
know I'm curious to see how these AI
algorithms when they start writing
articles are going to try to test the
algorithm
to figure out what goes viral
that's going to be very interesting to
see and also to see how quickly AI is
going to be able to crack that code and
figure algorithms like this out it's
going to be that that's why I've
described the AI apocalypse as people
walking around dressed like popcorn corn
on the cob turning on a TV and there's
nothing like corn commercials and then
you know you're going on the internet
and like everyone's phone is hit like a
piece of corn and all anyone talks about
is the new coin that just came out and
the reason being
the AI will latch onto something it
thinks is popular force it and then
create a cycle like it will create a
self-fulfilling prophecy of popularity
it'll know like if this article goes up
at three 3 17 p.m it's more likely to
get views if we posted an article about
corn yesterday at 117 and so it'll start
pre-con confluencing these these
behaviors to try and manipulate humans
to be at the right moment at the right
time to see the stuff but I do agree
that it's not for-profit news is kind of
funky anyway it was never really
supposed to be about making money
I don't well maybe it was I guess when
they started newspapers they were all
for-profit extraction yeah I mean it was
a service early on uh there's an old
newspaper we uh I was reading at an
antique shop or I can't remember where I
got it from
um it's like a bulletin and the news is
something literally like you know Bill
replaced his front door it was like the
news was literally just like what the
neighborhood was up to yeah and as the
world got bigger the news got got bigger
I bet Bill wasn't happy you know when
newspapers were just about what was
going on around the town of people were
like I don't think everyone needs to be
in my business they don't even know
about that new door it would it would be
like IRS is going to start wondering how
I got the money for a new door it's just
shut it down literally the news would be
like on the front page he would say
John's shoes selling a new nine size
nine model you know we talked to him
about it it's like seemingly innocuous
but this is what mattered and you're
like you're really like oh I'll go check
that out I'll go downtown and you know
see what's up in a way it was a simpler
time but those were also the times when
you'd get a letter in the mail saying
come you're going to fight a war that
you have no idea what's going on about
and you'll likely survive and then you
wouldn't and we ain't going back till
it's over over there now we know what's
going on in the world we can say no a
year 10 years beforehand and change the
course of War as a populist so that's I
wonder though so I I think it's good to
be informed I think it's good to know
about these things but then you wonder
especially at a broad level when people
aren't focused on local issues and are
looking more at National politics how
much a person can really affect I think
knowing more about what's actually going
on in your neighborhood with your own
school board and your own local
elections would probably be way more
productive in the long run yeah like uh
building a balloon and floating a
balloon both are important like the
building of the balloon is the local
structure structural organization but
once you've got that down you got to
learn how to float the balloon which is
geopolitics yeah I just don't think we
have the inflating of the balloon I was
gonna say I don't think we have the
inflation down but well we have the
inflation down
um I just think we haven't reached that
point where our local politics are
um as together as they should be yes not
enough people know how to build their
own structural balloon and so they're
screaming and trying to grab the one
that's already there and control it but
like you've gotta you've got to build
your own you know
here's what I think
for no reason
I think everybody should move to
Berkeley County West Virginia why why
how come
just cuz just cuz
moved to Berkeley County West Virginia
this is not Financial advice if you're
uh if you're planning uh we we welcome
y'all as neighbors
I'll I'll just say that um Jefferson
County is the Harpers Ferry area and
then just to the West is Berkeley County
Jefferson County is based and Berkeley
County is cringed and we need uh we need
some good neighbors to come and help
make West Virginia great again so as we
are seeking to you know obviously we're
building our studio the reason I bring
this up is because we're talking you
know in terms of local politics people
really don't pay attention and so as uh
I'll give a shout out to A.G Morrissey
because last night we were saying like
where's the action being taken and he
he's not the guy for this in West
Virginia some states and at the federal
level the AG is in charge in charge a
lot of this uh the Aging West Virginia
isn't as much so it's not necessarily on
him it's on the D.A but my understanding
is that Berkeley County is surprisingly
fairly woke and so what all that really
means is the people of West Virginia
especially Berkeley County who we know
for a fact are not on average lefties
have not done their civic duty and gone
and voted and paid attention to what was
going on at the local level and they
have allowed
for instance uh child drag shows for
children to happen in their jurisdiction
Jefferson County Bandit Berkeley County
is allowing it to take place and I
really doubt the uh the D.A will
actually do anything but you know I got
it so we'll see I think if more people
move out there and morrissey's running
for governor I think he's going to have
tremendous success in the upcoming
primary uh he's I think he's a
phenomenal AG he's been a leader on the
uh fighting the woke issues you know the
state of West Virginia divested uh from
BlackRock before any other state so you
know everybody focuses on how Ron
DeSantis and Florida divested but uh
Riley Riley I believe yeah Riley Moore
the state treasurer and Morrissey uh
they were the first state to divest and
so
um I think he's going to be a great
Governor as well if he gets the
opportunity Riley Moore is awesome man
he's been on the show a couple of times
he's just here a few weeks ago and I got
to say about Harpers Ferry West Virginia
one of the most beautiful cities I've
ever seen in my life seriously a small
San Francisco probably what it was like
in the 1860s right right around the gold
rush time uh it's like just buildings
that have been leveled to the ground I
would love to live in Harper's Ferry
I've kind of got my eyes and my focus on
Harper's Ferry right now and if it's
coming out woke whatever I don't care I
will transform that City I will be there
for those people I want to be part of
the local community and the local
governance
wow what a place to live with the
Divergence of those two rivers it's
beautiful it really is very beautiful
and the real estate prices out here are
incredible
um I know the governor the current
governor and some state legislators they
wanted to make West Virginia zero income
tax and uh if they end up doing that I
mean I I would move here in a heartbeat
yeah property uh property values will
definitely jump if they do that but it's
sad you see this happening in places
like Harpers Ferry where it's like this
beautiful little town it's illegal in
Harpers Ferry what are you talking about
Jefferson County is where Harper's Ferry
is they have specifically outlawed drag
shows oh no that's that's not just
that's not just what I'm talking about
but you Ian you mentioned it being woke
but you'll have these maybe it's not
maybe I don't know but you'll you'll
have these but you know you'll go there
and see pride flags and stuff I mean you
have these like beautiful little pockets
of the country that a lot of left-wing
people move from big cities to and then
start to fill up and hang their Flags
everywhere and but they're allowed to do
that I love it yeah I mean you're
allowed to purchase a place where you
want to it's just ironic because they're
the people who complain about
gentrification and people being
displaced but then they're fine Phil
exactly they're fine filling up these
conservative little areas and pushing
the original culture out I will say this
too because I looked it up and uh
according to West virginia.gov it does
say that the Attorney General is
responsible for state criminal law so uh
playing a critical role with regard to
save criminal law Prosecuting on behalf
of the state so but apparently the
argument I'm hearing is that this is
going to come down to the County D.A as
regards to having this lewd and
lascivious behavior in public involving
children so my view is just that uh you
know I bring this up one obviously it's
personal to us because we're we're
investing in the area and building in
the area
but uh if people don't pay attention to
their local politics don't be surprised
when Maga Country West Virginia
LX liberal District Attorneys who who
allow criminal activity you know what I
noticed Obama used to do is jog jog
around the city I don't know if he did
it a lot when he was president
yeah and I did used to do that in L.A
you want to talk about getting in touch
with your community jog around the
streets jog around the blocks just jog
by people's houses sometimes you see
them and you wave at them while you're
jogging it's awesome
yeah I'm more concerned about are you
paying attention to who's running yeah
what they believe is jogging not just
who's jogging and uh uh if you are not
voting your local elections don't be
surprised if one day you wake up and
there are you know adults walking around
thrusting their their naked bodies at
children and then when you call the
police the police say da says it's fine
well I'd like to give a shout out to
1776 project pack they've been uh
raising more money than any other group
to help elect uh good conservative
School Board candidates across the
country and they've winning at
incredible rates uh and then also
president Trump just introduced uh a new
policy that he'd like to implement where
you allow parents to vote on who's the
principal of your local school oh no
that's great thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time